Cause there's a limit to your strengths,
but God only knows to some
degree what that limit is.
You know,
people can be unbelievably tough,
unbelievably tough.
And I think it's even the more admirable
for human beings to be tough because
we're so conscious of how we can be
hurt and we're so conscious of what that
hurt can lead to.
You know,
you can have your family taken away
from you and you can be destroyed.
And the fact that you can be
courageous in the face of that at all,
it's something that is
absolutely unbelievable,
right?
And people deserve a lot more credit,
I think then people give themselves,
because the fact that we can be honorable
under conditions of life and death,
right?
Of suffering.
That's,
that's a testament to the human spirit.
And there's a profound anti-human ethos,
I think that pervades our culture.
You know,
that considers human beings
cancer's on the planet,
something like that,
you know,
and that there should be less of us.
It's the same spirit that motivated the
guy who wrote the book about it better
to have never been.
It's like,
I don't see it that way.
You know?
I mean,
I think people do pretty well for,
you know,
for having their leg caught in a bear
trap and their head caught in a vice,
they're actually doing pretty
well because life is really hard.
And the fact that we're not absolutely
brutal and murderous all the time is
really something remarkable given
what we actually have to contend with,
that we can go out of our way to be
honest and generous and altruistic and to
care for each other.
Yeah.
Under unbelievably dire circumstances
and to act notably sometimes under the
most trying conditions,
you know,
and soldier Knutson's Gulag archipelago.
He tells story after story of
people who acted a bismuth Lee,
but also people who under
the worst threats imaginable,
never sacrifice their character and
know when reading about that is really,
while it really makes you wonder,
that's,
that's what it does.